the major media are selectively
reporting the fbi and doj's briefing of
key lawmakers last week about that
informant in the trump presidential
campaign
it's typical of today's screaming
headlines abc's website blared
gowdy disputes trump's spy claim says
fbi acted properly
but that ignores a number of key points
oversight chair trey gowdy made on fox
last night
the first was that the doj made clear
that the president was not
and is not a target of the russia
investigation
despite the democrats constant
disinformation on that point
gowdy also could not explain why the fbi
did not simply
do that defensive briefing of the trump
campaign instead of relying
on an informant inside his campaign on
the angle last night former federal
prosecutor andy mccarthy laid out his
theory
there's no question that they spied on
the campaign
if you were looking at a corporation and
you thought that the corporation was
being corrupted by three people
you would go to the ceo and say i think
we have a problem here we need your
cooperation
what they did instead was send covert
operatives to pry
information out now this is why a number
of conservatives are unhappy that gowdy
kind of
muddied the waters or would downplay
trump's spy claims one of them is dan
bongino of nri tv
and also joining us is daniel goldman
former assistant u.s attorney for the
southern district of new york
great to see both of you uh dan bongino
first let's go to you
on this uh you know we invited gowdy on
the show
uh we want him to come on i think he's a
really smart guy
a little confusing kind of the way he
approached this issue although
a little bit misrepresented i think in
the press
but where do you come down on what he
said specifically about the spy gate
question
no i think gowdy's appearance was
disgraceful um i think you're being nice
to him i understand
you know laura but uh gr gowdy's
appearance is now being used as
propaganda by the left
and what he said was so completely out
of line and factually incorrect
laura let's just run through some basic
facts here okay
so according to gowdy the fbi ran it by
the book how the americans would have
wanted them to run the investigation
really
so why didn't they notify congress for
eight months laura
eight months about the investigation
when prior procedure was to notify
congress quarterly
on sensitive investigations you know
another question for you
if they ran it by the book how is it
that two suspicious potentially felony
leaks of information
happened in both october and january to
the new york times of washington post
is that an example mr gowdy of of a
finely tuned investigation
run like the americans would have wanted
by the way hidden from congress
you know seriously give me a break he
did nothing but feed
the leftist propaganda machine yesterday
and he should go back and clarify
those outrageous absurd remarks well i
think he's
obsessing over the definition of spy
within the intelligence community versus
an informant in an ongoing investigation
which i think is beyond the point
daniel goldman i want to play for you a
sound bite from
jason chaffetz earlier let's watch
it jeff sessions is the attorney general
is there a name only he's absolutely
worthless
the sooner the president names the new
attorney general the better
he should never have recused himself he
didn't need to in a counterintelligence
operation
this is of course regarding the trump
tweet today
commenting on what gowdy did say that a
lot of us took note of which is that you
could have had
any top lawyer be the attorney general
and meanwhile you pick a guy who
everyone likes or liked
but accused himself right off the bat
your reaction
well i i think that the president
probably should do his homework a little
bit more because this was an
obvious recusal under department of
justice regulations this was not a
should not have been a surprise to him
or his lawyers
and so the fact that he then announced
that he was recusing himself
because he was an integral player in the
campaign
and therefore could not oversee an
investigation into the campaign
should not have been a surprise the the
other
problem that that i see as a former
federal prosecutor
about the way that trump views sessions
and the attorney general is that he
seems to be talking a lot about
wanting someone who's loyal to him which
on its face is fine
you know he gets to choose his cabinet
and and i get that
but what he's really indicating and
implying
in making that statement is that he
wants someone loyal to him at the top of
the justice department
who will squash an investigation into
either him or his campaign
associates children or whatever you have
of it wait a second well
dan let me just say this was was eric
holder
perceived to be loyal to barack obama
because i think you could go through a
number of scenarios where you could
argue that
eric holder went above and beyond what
the left is now saying uh trump should
you know
have the relationship with with uh
sessions so it seems like that loyalty
went real
deep between the two of them on whether
it was the irs investigation
how they handled fast and furious how
they did the rosen
oversight whether the president knew
anything about any of this was ever
briefed on it
i mean you couldn't get any information
out of these people so i think loyalty
really mattered to obama at the top of
the justice department
i think loyalty in some respects matters
but i think
yeah the president's wingman he called
himself well i don't know if that's true
or not but
yeah it's true that's what he called
himself when it's true when trump
is saying that he wants loyalty
as a former organized crime prosecutor i
hear
something very different well no i hear
something very different than
wanting someone who is close to him who
is loyal to him
the critical difference that i think you
have to acknowledge both of you
is that barack obama was not under
investigation
by the department of justice so whatever
you whether you like it or not dan
he is under investigation so you have to
recognize that there needs to be some
division between
that investigation into the president
and the the department of justice yeah
well they also he also is the chief
executive officer of the
of the executive branch of the of the
government and as chief executive
officer
if he wanted to constitutionally danbone
jeannie you know he can fire anyone he
wants now whether it's politically
appropriate
i think daniel goldman is right it
wouldn't be politically appropriate to
do that that would
send everyone into a frenzy but if he
decided he want to get rid of comey and
get rid of comey if he decided he wants
to get rid of rosenstein
who was a disaster from the beginning i
would argue you should get a rosenstein
i mean get rid of sessions
if you want so what you're saying though
is that he's he's sorry
what you're saying though is he's
completely above the law and that he can
fire anybody for gina's gotta answer
corrupt
practices dan you're just seriously
you're just making stuff up now and i
wish you would stop
doing that um you said before that you
want the president you see
he's looking for someone to quash these
investigations uh i'm
i'm guessing you're not familiar with
the details of the case
because it's already open source that
the president said multiple times
that if there was a russian intelligence
asset in his campaign trying to
compromise his campaign
that he wants to know about it so dan i
i'm
i'm you may be hearing this for the
first time and i'll give you a chance to
retract that
but who quashes an investigation while
asking the fbi simultaneously to
investigate it
i'll wait for your answer on that you
may not know those facts he wants a fair
investigation i think i think he wants
it to be fair
i think he wants an attorney general who
doesn't melt when
when the new york times editorial board
gets all upset about a recusal that he
never had to do
uh so i think that's probably what he
wants i think that's what most president
won
dan i mean look he had to do it under
the department of justice regulations he
didn't no he didn't why didn't you don't
think that he was he was
an integral part of that because because
because kislyak saw him at a party and
kislyak
stopped that they stopped at his office
he does nothing he has to do with
russian collusion he had zero
to do with russian collusion it doesn't
have i think that was convenient it has
to do with the fact that he was an
integral part of the campaign and the
campaign
was the subject of the investigation or
it was involved in an investigation on
protection
grounds that was started with a with a
ridiculous informant who
who was trolling for god knows how did
you know that money how do you know what
the informant was doing you're saying
jeff sessions was was intricately
involved in some
way in the russia investigation no i'm
not i'm saying jeff sessions was
involved in the campaign
that was a prudential decision that he
made and i would say it was
not i have the rights here i don't think
it was
all right read the regs they're very how
many of the obama people ever recused
themselves uh rarely effectively because
obama was never investigated
i'm not i'm not here to defend obama
versus trump i'm just saying to you
that if there is a confidential
informant
that is uh that has information about
wrongdoing in the campaign
i do think this is important all right
guys we'll have you back
fantastic segment